california where crews are in a
desperate fight to stop the cal door
fire as it races toward heavily
populated areas around lake tahoe the
fire has already burned more than 300
square miles and destroyed hundreds of
homes
around 50 thousand people are now under
evacuation orders and the flames are now
just three miles from the resort city of
south lake tahoe which has not seen
danger like this in decades
carter evans is in nearby myers and near
the flames himself carter good morning
well good morning we are at the front of
the fire right now and as you can see
there is a lot of fuel to burn now we
have seen some extreme fire behavior
this week flames reaching above the
treetops but the winds are calm right
now that's the good news the bad news
that red flag warning is in effect
throughout today
this is what firefighters are facing
choking smoke massive flames and
relentless wind whipping the cal door
fire closer to tens of thousands of
homes around lake tahoe
crews spent hours tuesday dowsing spot
fires working to save as many homes as
possible and trying to hold back a
massive wall of flames they're facing
gusts of more than 35 miles an hour as
the fire continues to move further into
the tahoe basin military aircraft at 18
000 feet above are sending back infrared
images like these to guide firefighters
to hot spots hidden by the thick smoke
very very sensitive sensors can pick up
any signature of heat we'll plot it
we'll get that down to the firefighter
on the ground they can go attack it you
can see the fire just taking off in this
brush in fact little fire whirls right
there but firefighters are letting it
burn while the wind is calm to clear out
the fuel between here and the homes just
about a hundred yards away
snow making machines were running full
force tuesday night as firefighters
moved in to protect the heavenly ski
resort from the fast-moving flames these
densely forested areas haven't seen
significant wildfires in more than 80
years this one's really scary i'm afraid
it's going to burn down a jewel of
california even the wildlife including
these bears were forced to seek refuge
from the flames and as the erratic
wildfire closes in on this now deserted
resort paradise fire crews are ready for
battle the same winds are coming through
these areas are ridden with strong heavy
fuels that can easily ignite spread this
fire quickly
there is a bulldozer line cut just a few
feet in this direction and right behind
that is an entire neighborhood that
firefighters are trying to protect
trying to keep the fire from going over
that line there are four thousand
firefighters on this fire right now
backed up by one thousand members of the
california national guard vlad all right
carter thank you very much